bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro et live ce mercredi
16 juin 2021 c'est une rencontre sous
haute tension qui se déroule à genève
aujourd'hui dans quelques minutes le
président américain joe biden rencontre
son homologue russe vladimir poutine
cette réunion très attendue entre les
deux hommes a lieu dans la foulée des
réunions des dirigeants du g7 et de
l'otan qui se sont tenues au royaume uni
et en belgique
ces derniers jours il s'agit du premier
tête à tête entre les deux chefs d'état
depuis l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche pour commenter ce sommet
en direct j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés philippe gelie qui est avec nous
directeur adjoint de la rédaction en
charge de l'international ancien
correspondant du figaro à washington
merci d'être avec nous philippe
aujourd'hui nous serons également si la
technique le permet laure mandeville qui
sera avec nous par téléphone depuis
genève en suisse où elle sera
physiquement présentes sur les lieux de
cette rencontre entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine leur mondeville qui je
précisais grand reporter au figaro elle
a été correspondante quelques années au
figaro une correspondante aux journées
du journal à moscou et puis plus
récemment correspondante également du
figaro à washington
elle sera dans quelques minutes en
direct avec nous et vous qui nous
suivait également sur figaro l'arrivée
sur youtube vous n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions à nous faire part de vos
commentaires
nous sommes là pour vous répondre et
philippe gelie sera un plaisir de
répondre à toutes vos interrogations je
vois que vous êtes un certain nombre
déjà sur le chat de youtube je dis
bonjour à burgos carmen à nelly octopus
y à claude therrien qui déjà font
quelques commentaires sur cette
rencontre à venir
nelly octopus i qui nous dit je pense
que cette rencontre au sommet va être
fort cordiale mais certainement
croustillant claude dit et rien nous dit
quand elle avec les présidents
américains et les russes ça n'a jamais
été une entente cordiale et ça remonte à
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
ben vous n'hésitez pas à nous faire part
donc comme ses internautes de vos
questions et vos commentaires comme je
vous le disais
sommes là pour vous répondre nous avons
depuis genève quelques images de la
effets de ce qu'il se passe en direct je
crois que nous avons en particulier des
images du centre ville de genève où
certains journalistes attendent le
passage des convois des chefs d'état qui
doivent se rendre sur un lieu bien
précis où la rencontre doit avoir lieu
c'est une une ville à la ville à la
grange qui pour l'anecdote est une
bâtisse du xviiie siècle poser dans un
vaste parc au bord du lac léman le cadre
est magnifique c'est en plein coeur de
genève et depuis une semaine on peut
lire ça sur le figaro immobilier
l'endroit est une ruche d'activité à
l'intérieur des artisans ont retouché
dorures et moulures les lourds
chandelier ont été nettoyés et les
meubles déplacer pour être prêts à
accueillir les deux chefs d'état et
leurs délégations
philippe gelie je me tourne vers vous on
sait cette rencontre importante attendue
elle clôt à la tournée européenne du
président américain joe biden entamé le
9 juin dernier
c'est une rencontre sous haute tension
de certains disent également une
rencontre bras de fer est ce que la
tension entre les deux pays est à ce
point élevé les la relation entre les
deux pays et est au plus bas
oui probablement depuis la fin de la
guerre froide parce que pour les
américains
là les nuisances causées par la russie 2
vladimir poutine se multiplient et ce
qui est nouveau c'est qu'elles
atteignent jusqu'à l'intérieur même du
territoire américain sous la forme de
cyberattaque mais aussi d'un terreau
faire de campagne de désinformation
d'interférence dans les élections etc
c'est un des paramètres nous vous très
important de cette rencontre qui fait
qu'elle est différente des rencontres
habituelles traditionnel un petit guerre
froide qu'on avait connue à partir de
reggane et et gorbatchev en 1985 déjà à
genève d'ailleurs cette fois ci à deux
paramètres nouveau à mon sens c'est un
pour une fois la russie interfère dans
les affaires intérieures américaines
d'une manière qui agace prodigieusement
les américains et s'éteindre une des
choses que les russes ont toujours
reproché aux américains c'est à dire
d'intervenir non seulement dans leurs
affaires intérieures en terme de non
respect de la démocratie pour le
harcèlement des opposants etc mais aussi
dans leur environnement ce que la russie
appelle son étranger proche qui va de
l'ukraine au caucase et c'est donc à une
espèce d'équilibré des forces qui est
nouveau le deuxième paramètre qui me
sont tout à fait neuf c'est que la
russie n'est plus l'ennemi numéro un des
états unis
le grand rival c'est la chine est l'un
des objectifs à mon sens de joe biden
avec cette rencontre c'est justement
d'essayer de régler ce problème devenu
relativement secondaire attention il
s'agit pas de le minimiser à l'excès
mais relativement secondaire que pose la
russie aux etats unis pour pouvoir se
concentrer sur la chine
un problème relativement secondaire est
ce que ça veut dire que la russie
aujourd'hui face à la chine n'est plus
considéré comme un adversaire par les
américains si elle est un adversaire
parce que le mode de fonctionnement de
vladimir poutine s'est quand même qu'il
mesure un peu sa puissance à sa capacité
de nuisance
il n'a pas bien sûr ce sont les deux
plus les deux premiers arsenaux
nucléaires donc on ne peut pas négliger
la puissance militaire de la russie
mais le budget militaire de la russie
ses 60 milliards de dollars par an celui
des etats unis c'est 700 milliards de
dollars par an celui des autres des
membres européens de l'otan hors états
unis
c'est 260 milliards donc on est quand
même dans un rapport de force qui n'est
pas nécessairement un avantage la russie
même si la russie a montré qu'elle
n'avait pas peur d'utiliser ses forces
armées
ce qui est parfois souvent aussi le cas
des américains bien sûr c'est plus c'est
plus une question de géostratégie
on n'est plus dans le schéma où l'urss
et le bloc occidental chercher à annuler
l'autre ou à louer ou à le vaincre où
elle détruire le les états unis n'ont
pas pour objectif de détruire la russie
et la russie d'un certain pas l'ambition
de détruire les états unis en revanche
il ya une vraie compétition systémique
entre la chine et les états unis qui
accapare toute l'attention du président
américain est à mon sens il
commence par vladimir poutine pour
essayer de canaliser ce problème là qui
est cac analysable qui est gérable
à son avis est passé ensuite aux choses
sérieuses avec la russie avec la chine
si vous nous rejoignez à cet instant sur
figaro live et sur le conte figaro live
youtube pardon en direct nous allons
vivre en direct la rencontre attendue
entre joe biden président américain et
son homologue russe vladimir poutine
les deux hommes doivent se rencontrer
aujourd'hui dans quelques minutes
une entente est un sommet qui est prévu
depuis peu on va dire ça ne fait pas
très longtemps fait que cette somme a
été arrangé il est très attendue parce
qu'on attend on dit que c'est un sommet
sous haute tension on l'a vu avec
philippe gelie vous n'hésitez pas à nous
faire part de vos commentaires de votre
question vous êtes déjà effectivement un
certain nombre à être présent sur les
tchats du figaro et sur le tchat
youtube est ce que philippe gelie on
peut considérer que c'est une rencontre
historique aujourd'hui on peut toujours
qualifié une telle rencontre historique
c'est une première entre les deux hommes
en tant que dans leurs fonctions
actuelles bien sûr ils se sont
rencontrés dans le passé puisque poutine
est au pouvoir depuis 20 ans et joe
biden lui même dans le circuit de la
politique étrangère d'abord à la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat qu'il a présidée sous bush puis
comme vice président monde a raté par
obama pour un certain nombre de missions
internationales et il y à cette fameuse
anecdote qu'il faut peut-être rappeler
absolument entre jordan et et et
vladimir poutine qui n'est racontait que
par le côté américain donc c'est quand
même aussi une façon de dire j'ai pas
peur de dire à poutine
ce que je pense de lui mais en tout cas
en 2014 joe biden a raconté au new
yorker que trois ans plus tôt en 2011
lorsqu'il avait rencontré poutine
il lui avait dit je vous regarde dans
les yeux et je ne vois pas d'âme
évidemment ça fait écho à ce qu'avait
dit george bush en 2001 lors de sa
première rencontre après le 11 septembre
après les attentats avec poutine où il
avait dit je je le regarde au fond des
yeux j'ai j'ai eu une impression de
sonam cents à fait sens et je pense que
c'est quelqu'un de direct de fiable et
que nous allons pouvoir coopérer
évidemment il a été relativement démenti
par les faits ensuite donc c'est une
manière pour joe biden de prendre le
contre-pied de 2,7
vision optimiste une autre anecdote
aussi qu'on peut citer que les beaucoup
plus récente celle ci c'est à la
question d'un journaliste américain qui
faisait au mois de mars un entretien
avec le président américain joe biden
à la question pensez vous que la
demi-heure cantine est un killer un
coeur joe biden a répondu oui oui suivi
un échange un peu de cours d'école
diront certains entre les deux chefs
d'état oui il s'en est suivi
surtout un rappel de l'ambassadeur russe
de washington à moscou ils ont quand
même assez mal pris côté russe et la
réponse non pas de petits directement
mais de son entourage ça a été de dire
qu'en gros job high tone et joe biden
était un vieux gâteux quoi ils ont à
peine mis les formes
bon ça vole pas très haut la question
avait été posée là aussi c'est le
contexte qui compte c'est à dire que on
pourquoi demande toi à dubaï d'annecy
poutine est un tueur parce que la
question avait été posée à donald trump
lors d'une interview sur fox news quatre
ans plus tôt et la réponse de tram
c'était mais vous croyez qu'il ya pas de
tueur aux états unis que dans ce pays on
n'est pas des tueurs aussi donc ça avait
beaucoup choqué les américains parce
qu'ils ont une vision quand même du bien
contre le mal
il faut bien se dire que à washington
énormément de gens qui travaillent dans
les milieux de la sécurité nationale de
la politique étrangère ont un logiciel
qui date de l'époque de la guerre froide
il n'a pas bougé et qui n'a pas beaucoup
bougé qui n'a pas beaucoup évolué et
c'est d'ailleurs une chose intéressante
c'est pas idéal parce que bynum fait
partie de cette génération
il avait lui-même ce logiciel de
considérer que le grand rival de
l'amérique c'est la russie et ils sont
changement est assez récent et il s'est
converti à il a changé d'âne midi la
force des choses et il a identifié la
chine comme un rival beaucoup plus
dangereux on les voit à l'instant ces
images de la villa la grange bâtisse du
xviiie siècle au bord du lac léman au
centre de genève en suisse
villa est un lieu historique dans lequel
devraient se rencontrer dans quelques
minutes
le président américain joe biden et son
homologue russe vladimir poutine on
attend l'heure leur arrivée qui devrait
être imminente maintenant merci de nous
suivre en direct sur figaro live et sur
youtube vous nous faites part de vos de
vos questions de vos commentaires nous
sommes avec philippe gelie directeur
adjoint de la rédaction en charge de
l'international et dans quelques minutes
on aura possiblement laure mandeville
qui est en direct sur place à genève
avec respect qui était un habitué des
tchats du figaro sur youtube nous
demande pas de conférence de presse
prévue entre poutine et baydan bien si
il ya des conférences de presse qui sont
prévus à la suite de leurs travaux tous
les deux de ces sessions de travaux cet
après midi en revanche ce sont les
conférences de presse en solo est ce qu
on sait pourquoi
chacun de ces chefs d'état ne veut pas
intervenir avec l'autre les conférences
de presse commune d'un président
américain
avec vladimir poutine c'est une longue
succession de de mise en embarras du
président américain par le président
russe
je me souviens avoir couvert avec laure
d'ailleurs en 2007 un sommet bush
poutine à bratislava où toutes les
questions sur le non respect de la
démocratie et la traque des opposants en
russie avait obtenu pour réponse une
mise en cause très violente par poutine
de la démocratie américaine des
agissements des soldats américains en
irak avec la prison d'abou ghraïb le les
humiliations qu'ils avaient subi des les
prisonniers irakiens qui était vraiment
des violations des droits de l'homme
très fort et bush était complètement
déstabilisé donc byden connaît la
musique est d'emblée il a dit pas de
qu'auprès de conférence de presse
commune pourquoi parce que avec poutine
la conférence de presse commune
c'est un jeu de catch ccco montre ses
muscles et on essaye d'embarrasser le
voisin là ils vont parler en privé
1h30 en tête à tête puis ce sera élargi
aux conseillers et aux ministres qui les
accompagnent la rencontre est censé
durer quand même quatre ou cinq heures
donc pratiquement tout cas jusqu'à
jusqu'à lundi soir
et ensuite chacun donnera son
interprétation des choses
de son côté mais on est ils échapperont
à cette mise en danger d'être c'est à
dire que poutine un grand talent pour
savoir prendre le contre-pied de son
interlocuteur et le mettre en porte à
faux
on dit aussi que joe biden n'est pas
forcément c'est pas un de ses atouts de
il s'est facilement déstabilisé il peut
avoir un coup de fatigue alors à lille
peut être un peu hésitant et ça peut
énormément le des services et desservir
face à un interlocuteur qui joue la
carte de si c'était le cas oui c'est
vrai mais servirait jeu
on suppose on présuppose que byden est
un petit peu fatiguée parce qu il a 78
ans et poutine à 68,3 le convoi en ce
moment alors je pense que c'est le
convoi
difficile à dire on ne peut pas le dire
vraiment tout à fait un combo a des
devoir
la bête comme en appel c'est plutôt le
convoi américain c'est un combat
américains parce que je vois le camion
un radar et ça c'est typique du moto
club américain oui mais philippe gelie
si le président américain fait toujours
venir d'outre-atlantique son son
véhicule blindé
j'assume tout déplacement à l'étranger
en général mais ils ont fait venir deux
parce qu' il ne doit pas savoir dans
laquelle des deux voitures officielles
se trouve vraiment les présidents au cas
où un terroriste et série 2-1
lance-roquettes sur une voiture
l'ignorer il aurait une chance sur deux
de devises est la mauvaise on est en
direct au figaro dans les sillons du
figaro et nous avons les images en
direct de genève où doit se dérouler
cette rencontre ce sommet entre le
président américain et le président
russe ils vont se retrouver dans genève
dans un lieu bien précis que vous voyez
en ce moment à l'image une très belle
bâtisse la ville à la grange qui est
situé à côté du lac léman c'est là que
la rencontre doit avoir lieu
on vous la montrera cette rencontre
cette poignée de mots clés les photos
qui seront faites des deux hommes des
deux dirigeants avant qu'il ne
s'engouffre à l'intérieur de cette
bâtisse pour pour travailler ensemble
jusqu'en début de soirée
et dans un second temps dans un
troisième temps les deux hommes
donneront l'un et l'autre pas ensemble
des conférences de presse en solo est ce
qu'on sait philippe gelie dans quel état
d'esprit et de quelle façon joe biden à
bord de cet entretien on peut le
le déduire delà du planning de ce2
de ce rendez vous parce que hayden a
pris soin de bien rencontrer tous ses
alliés occidentaux avant d'aller voir
poutine est vraiment l'idée est
d'ailleurs exprimé par les conseillers
de bill dann notamment le conseiller à
la sécurité nationale james sullivan
c'était d'aller avec le vent dans le dos
comme on dit voir poutine en montrant
regardez le g7 n'est plus les plus
grandes puissances économiques dont il
faut le rappeler
la russie a été exclu après l'invasion
de l'ukraine et de la crimée l'annexion
de la crimée en 2014 puisque avant
c'était le g8 + l'otan plus lieu
voilà il ya un camp occidental qui a eu
des conversations plus tôt plutôt
consensuel qui est assez unie et c'est
fort de ce soutien là que biden va voir
poutine aujourd'hui en me disant voilà
je représente les états unis en premier
lieu mais j'ai aussi avec moi beaucoup
d'alliés voici le convoi américain je
suppose puisqu'on a vu un petit drapeau
sur le capot de ses premiers véhicules
blindés le deuxième véhicule
voilà qui arrive devant la villa
lagrange où doit se tenir ce sommet
entre les deux chefs d'état le président
américain joe biden qui fait le lit par
le président de la confédération
helvétique dont le nom m'échappe départ
melun qui est là et qui l'attend ils se
sont rencontrés hier puisque joe biden
est arrivé hier dans l'après midi à
genève et
le président la confédération helvétique
et joe biden se sont déjà vus et se sont
déjà entretenus
donc nous voyons sur ces images the
beast comme vous dites philippe gelie
c'est le surnom donné à celui là enfin
le surnom pardonner par la presse avait
donné par le cyclo services ares
carrément ça n'est pas la presse qui a
surnommés ces véhicules de cette marque
c'est le nom de code que les que les
agents de sécurité ont dans leurs
oreillettes donc the beast est garée
devant l'entrée de cette bâtisse la
ville à la grange où doit avoir lieu le
sommet on le voit les drapeaux russe
suisses et américains décorent l'entrée
de cette bâtisse on devrait voir dans
quelques secondes le président joe biden
sorti de son véhicule et dans quelques
minutes devrait arriver le président
russe vladimir poutine pour une poignée
de main on va dire une première un
premier tête à tête face aux caméras et
au public et à la presse
voilà donc ce tiers cette puissance
invitante ce confédération helvétique
qui sera au milieu d'eux du tandem
poutine byden un peu plus tard c'est la
vedette du jour c'est la vraie vedette
du jour c'est guy parmelin
c'est vrai quand on parle peu en général
c'est pas forcément ni la personnalité
politique ni le chef détails mais le
pays qui est mis en avant
régulièrement dans dans les médias quand
on parle de diplomatie et de politique
étrangère
peut-être sur le deuxième volet de votre
question juste avant l'arrivée 2
du président américain le côté côté
poutine l'état d'esprit je pensais
beaucoup plus détendu que du côté de
byden parce que poutine a déjà ce qu'il
voulait c'est à dire il n'est pas
demandeur de ce sommet évidemment il est
très content qu'on le lui offert parce
que en termes de stature internationale
c'est très important il est le premier
dirigeant d'un pays qui n'est pas allié
des états unis être à avoir l'honneur
d'une rencontre bilatérale à un vrai
sommet sur toute la journée plusieurs
heures de dialogue et en plus
l'agenda de cette rencontre reste très
très floue il n'y a pas d'objectif on
s'attend pas à ce que ce soir ces deux
hommes sortent de là et nous annonce des
mesures très concrètes alors par rapport
à ce que vous dit fils et j'ai dit que
le président russe vladimir poutine
n'est pas demandeur pourquoi at il
accepté finalement ça rend cette
rencontre en quoi ce talent ça le sert
finalement encore une fois d'abord en
termes de statut de 2,2 de fierté
nationale et internationale de ce que ça
veut dire qu'il était finalement il cède
à l'invitation d'un pays où on accepte
une invitation et c'est pas parce qu'on
discute avec un quelqu'un qu'on
considère comme un ennemi ou un
adversaire un rival que on s'affaiblit
bien au contraire certains vous le
pensez probablement pas parce que c'est
l'objet même de la diplomatie vous devez
certes parlé avec vos amis mais vous
devez encore plus parler avec ceux qui
ne sont pas d'accord avec vous qui ont
une autre vision du monde qui défendent
d'autres intérêts et qui taillent des
croupières sur la scène internationale
avec cela c'est vraiment important de
parler et la situation vous le demandiez
un peu plus tôt entre les etats-unis et
la russie est-elle aujourd'hui que il
est nécessaire encore une fois il n'ya
pas un objectif concret bien défini à
l'avancé mais il est nécessaire
d'essayer de cadres et cette relation
pour éviter qu'elle ne dégénère
davantage
elle pourrait dégénérer elle pourrait
bien sûr dégénéré
imaginez demain que baden pousse encore
plus qu'il ne l'a fait jusqu'à
maintenant à l'intégration d'ukraine
dans le temps on a aujourd'hui dans le
figaro une interview très intéressante
de john experts du moscow carnac dit
instinctif de moscou qui nous dit le
jour où les américains donnent leur feu
vert à l'entrée imminente de l'ukraine
dans le temps il peut y avoir une guerre
préventive de la russie contre l'ukraine
pour détruire le régime ukrainien tient
peut-être pas pour conquérir toute
l'ukraine met donc bien sûr que ça peut
dégénérer davantage on a vu au mois de
mars la russie déployé des dizaines de
milliers d'hommes et de matériels
militaires sur les frontières à
proximité des frontières de l'ukraine il
n'y a pas ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement des conflits gelés
c'est simplement des conflits qui n'ont
pas trouvé de résolutions depuis des
années mais en fait ces conflits là son
show notre reporter patrick saint paul a
fait une longue tournée de toute la
ligne de front en ukraine il n'y a pas
plus de trois semaines et je peux vous
dire que le reportage qu'il a rapporté
montré que c'était chaud et pas froid
n'est pas gelé nous sommes en direct sur
figaro live et sur youtube pour vous
faire vivre cette rencontre entre le
président américain joe biden et son
homologue russe vladimir poutine qui est
attendue dans quelques minutes sur le
site de la ville à la grange au centre
de genève dans un magnifique parc c'est
une une villa d'une bâtisse un but 18e
siècle où se trouvent déjà
joe biden le président américain dont on
a vu l'arrivée il ya quelques minutes il
a été reçu par le président de la
confédération helvétique
guy parmelin qui est à l'honneur
aujourd'hui est qu'il est depuis hier et
d'ailleurs kriss kross qui est un
habitué un fidèle des commentaires sur
le choc du figaro.fr nous dit guy
parmelin est un homme à connaître malgré
sa discrétion c'est un homme efficace et
humble vous êtes un certain nombre
encore à nous faire part de vos
commentaires on va poser vos questions à
philippe gelie qui est avec nous à mes
côtés en direct dans le sillon du figaro
nous
dont l'arrivée de vladimir poutine dans
quelques minutes mais vous êtes aussi un
certain nombre à faire des commentaires
nombreux sur la dîmière poutine et sur
joe biden sur leflux chat de youtube
j'y reviendrai je poserai vos questions
dans quelques secondes à un philippe
gelie tout à l'heure je le disais
certains ne penseront que finalement à
accorder à belleu voilà ça y est nous
avons le venir poutine qui est arrivé
qui est sur le pont de la balle si
j'aurais très voilà très dense clé déjà
le président russe à gauche la miss des
miss poutine guy parmelin le président
de la confédération helvétique au milieu
et joe biden le président américain à
droite les visages les visages fermés
oui absolument vous laisse vivre ces
images assez statique et de ces
présidents qui semble gêner un peu
d'être là pour pour tout in c'est quand
même le son cinquième président
américain depuis qu'il est aux commandes
de la russie donc il est assez rompu à
ce genre d'exercice est clairement il ya
un body language l'acquis et qui affirme
langage du corps le poutine ne va pas se
laisser intimider ça c'est déjà écrit
sur son front rapprochement des deux
hommes une poignée de main sourire sans
plus
c'est vrai que joe baydan fait un petit
peu plus vieux
alors que les portes se referment
arrivent vont maintenant travailler
ensemble mais on ne les reverra
probablement pas avant 18 ou 19 heures
ce qu'il faut qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
la très brièvement deux de ces quelques
secondes de ses voix de celle des parler
c'est à dire que l'art expressions
faciales est liée au fait que l'objet
principal de cette rencontre c'est
d'affirmer de rappeler à l'autre quelles
sont ces lignes rouges et pour poutine
les lignes rouges c'est encore une fois
ne vous mêlez pas de nos affaires
intérieures ne nous donnait pas des
leçons de démocratie et surtout
n'empiétait pas sur notre environnement
proche
notre étranger proche notre zone
d'influencé traditionnelle les les
analystes russes 10,6
une entrée de l'eau de l'ukraine dans
l'otan ce serait comme nous mettre le
canon d'un fusil sur la tempe
donc on voit les enjeux existentielle
tels qu'ils sont perçus du côté russe
pour byden encore une fois c'est moins
grave
la russie cet agaçant c'est énervant
c'est embêtant on pirate des pipes lines
on pirate une entreprise informatique
qui tourne à paralyser quand même neuf
agences fédérales et une centaine
d'entreprises américaines tout ça avec
des logiciels qui ne sont pas
nécessairement manipuler directement par
l'état russe mais qui sont abrités par
la russie en échange d'une du fait qu'
il y a dans les codages et ça ça a été
démontré par les informaticiens dans les
codages de ces virus des des mécanismes
qui les maintiennent à l'écart des sites
en cyrillique louis donc la russie
autorise un certain nombre de pirates
informatiques à agir depuis son
territoire en ayant l'immunité contre
ces virus puisque évidemment vous ne
devez pas mordre la main qui vous
nourrit donc que ça c'est quelque chose
de très important sur l'agenda de joe
biden aujourd'hui il veut que ça cesse
et il va dire à petit si vous continuez
à mener ces attaques
ces attaques informatiques mais aussi
les campagnes de désinformation et les
tentatives d' influence des élections
américaines
vous allez avoir des rêves des routes
des sanctions encore plus lourde
économique mais aussi des représailles
et là évidemment les américains ne le
diront pas mais ils ont eux mêmes leurs
armes et d'accra ii à coeur de pirate
qui est qui monte en puissance de
manière très significative et la russie
va commencer à subir
oui ce qu'elle fait subir aux états unis
est-ce que ça c'est un des points
importants est ce que véritablement la
russie est vulnérable aux sanctions
américaines
oui elle est vulnérable aux sanctions
américaines l'économie russe
et poussive actuellement les que la
russie a été affecté par le cos vidal
aussi pour vous voyez le niveau de
rebond économique aux états unis déjà
très grand et la façon dont la russie a
beaucoup de mal l'économie russe se
porte mal c'est aussi une des raisons
pour lesquelles poutine est aussi
intransigeant avec ses avec ses
opposants
c'est parce que quand vous laissez des
agitateurs entre guillemets rappeler au
peuple que les magasins sont à moitié
vides et qu' il ya une oligarchie très
riche mais que la situation de la
population dans les provinces ne s'est
pas sensiblement améliorée depuis des
décennies ils peuvent rencontrer une
oreille favorable
donc tout est lié c'est parce que
l'économie russe ne se porte pas bien
sauf pour quelques uns très rare que la
démocratie est aussi est aussi
verrouillé en russie est ce qu'on sait
ce que souhaite véritablement vladimir
vladimirovitch in le président risque
est ce que finalement il n'est pas
souhaitable qu'il dit toujours un peu de
frictions avec les américains
souhaitable pour qui pour les russes
est-ce que trop sereine avec les
américains ça ne serait pas un peu des
femmes ont un talent et ne sera jamais
totalement sereine avec les états unis
parce que encore une fois la vraie
puissance de poutine et dans sa capacité
de nuisance de déstabilisation ça n'est
plus ça n'est plus l'urss année plus la
puissance qui était considéré comme
l'alter ego ils sont encore au même
niveau en termes d'armement nucléaire
oui mais qui songe aujourd'hui à en
arriver là c'est pas vraiment à l'ordre
du jour même si effectivement ils vont
en parler c'est à dire que si ces deux
hommes arrivent à trouver un point un
modus vivendi
appelons ça comme ça sur les choses
qu'il est qui les préoccupe le plus
personnellement c'est à dire leurs
lignes rouges respectives après
peut-être qu'ils peuvent arriver à
trouver un
une forme de de certains certaines
sujets sur lesquels positive et en
particulier la discussion sur les
arsenaux nucléaires qui est quelque
chose que les russes et les américains
ont toujours maintenu mais même au plus
bas de leur relation reprendre des
relations diplomatiques normales c'est
quelque chose qu'on pourrait s il si la
journée se passe bien on pourrait
apprendre en fin de journée que les deux
pays ont décidé de renvoyer leurs
ambassadeurs par exemple c'est un petit
geste symbolique mais ça voudrait dire
écoutez on a réussi à se parler on a
calmé le jeu on a dit ok on va on va
réinstaller nos diplomates en essayant
d'éviter qu'ils aient trop d'espions de
part et d'autre dans dans ses équipes
diplomatiques c'est un peu un jeu de
dupes on va dire ben on avancer l'union
mais de telle sorte qu'on ne fasse pas
trop non plus mais c'est chaque fois et
c'est vraiment l'objet de la diplomatie
c'est à dire oui comment arriver à
trouver un terrain d'un mode de
fonctionnement avec quelqu'un qui n'est
pas d'accord avec vous qui n'a pas les
mêmes intérêts que vous comment vous
dire quand ben laden aurait été exposé
ses lignes rouges à poutine
quand il lui aura dit arrête de faire
des attaques contre notre nos systèmes
informatiques nos infrastructures notre
système électoral que va lui dire
poutine poutine veut dire dans ce cas là
arrête de 2
d'armes et l'ukraine arrête de défendre
des opposants par exemple la russie
compare les opposants comme navalni qui
est en prison
on va y revenir à alexeï navalni 1 qui
cet opposant autres qui ont été
carrément assassiné avec le traitement
que réserve la justice américaine aux
manifestants entre guillemets du 6
janvier qui ont pris d'assaut le peu le
capital en dire mais vous les
pourchassent et vous les mettez en
prison qu'est ce que vous faites de
différents de nous oui donc on est sur
ce type de dialogue et la question c'est
qu'est-ce que poutine peut obtenir de
baden qui lui importe vraiment c'est à
dire fichez moi la paix dans ma zone
d'influencé et mêlez vous de vos
affaires ne vous mêlez pas de mes
affaires intérieures à ce moment là si
byron dit ok je vais lever le pied sur
sur l'ukraine et sur d'autres sujets
peut-être que poutine va dire ben vous
allez voir ça va se calmer au niveau de
l'image il y a peu de chances que les
états unis lèvent le pied comme buté sur
l'ukraine
oui parce que c'est une question de
valeurs il mais il y a une marge entre
ce que dit entre le discours et les
actes et poutine est dans le métier
depuis assez longtemps pour savoir que
ce qui compte ce sont les actes
donc s'il a quelques garanties de baden
qu' il ne va pas attiser les braises en
ukraine et qui va calmer les dirigeants
ukrainiens plutôt que de l'est plutôt
que de les encourager sur la voie qui
est quand même de confrontation avec la
russie le président ukrainien zelensky à
déplorer juste avant le sommet que jobs
hayden ne l'est pas rencontrer avant de
rencontrer poutine par exemple un signe
donc montre qu'un autre nouveauté les
paroles il ya la marge pour des gestes
d'apaisement
on va dire philippe gelie je crois que
nous sommes en direct avec laure
mandeville un grand reporter pour le
figaro et qui est sur place en ce moment
à genève avec nous on est très heureux
de vous avoir leur mandeville la
connexion dans le mans est bonne on doit
pouvoir vous entendre vous avez vécu en
direct l'arrivée de joe biden en
présence du président de la
confédération
helvétique dit parmelin et puis on a vu
sur le perron de cette bâtisse la ville
à la grange la présence également de
vladimir poutine les trois hommes ont
posé ensemble et puis après on assister
à cette poignée de main racontez nous un
peu ce qui s'est passé sur place et
comment vous l'avez vécu goût oui en
fait c'est vrai qu'il y a explosé il y a
une
un contraste je dirais entre deux côtés
absolument serein de cet endroit la
splendeur des lieux celle apposée sur
les bords du lac léman avec une vue
magnifique et vers un temps absolument
enchanteur puisque le soleil taf ici sur
genève et le temps est absolu d'une
langue glorieux mais évidemment la
tension presque qui est vraiment dans
l'air entre les etats-unis et la russie
pour cette rencontre au sommet et donc
les gens que je vous ai perdu vous voit
plus là avec nous et on vous voit oui
oui les dents et donc la halle à l'état
de tension de cette relation
sinon vous pouvez tenir le téléphone
face à vous oui excusez moi en fait
c'est pas été très pratique puisque je
suis sur la terrasse pour essayer
m'isoler par rapport aux gens excusez
moi les aléas du direct exactement aux
philippines
on a on a senti avec philippe gelie à la
vue de ces images qu'on a diffusé en
direct une tension entre les deux hommes
et en particulier du côté de de vladimir
poutine cette mâchoire crispée 1 s'était
pas extrêmement chaleureux en revanche
pour la poignée de main il ya eu quand
même un petit sourire poli on va dire
vous l'avez senti cette tension
oui moi aussi j'étais un petit peu loi
parce qu'ils ont installé des espèces de
barrage chaque camp est un peu dans ses
lignes et moi je suis dans le pool russe
mais c'est vrai qu'on l'on
on le sent aussi d'avant par exemple la
manière dont se comportent les
journalistes c'est parce que il ya
beaucoup de journalistes pro kremlin en
a qui sont présents pendant sept dans
cette manifestation et c'est vrai que
même dans les commentaires qui te
faisait sur ce à quoi on est en train de
l'assister moi j'ai été très frappée à
la fois par les espèces de petites
piques sur regardez il ya le vieux qui
va arriver mais il sort pas de la
voiture est ce qu'il est endormi parlant
de dryden donc d'allusions à ils
essayent il est sur le tapis rouge
mais il ne verra pas donc ce qui était
une allusion au fait que qui l'avez vous
avez dérapé dans le temps les marches
d'un ample d'avion en fait donc c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui est
très présente dans la propagande russe
que en fait le président mbaye donne
était affaibli que des plus vieux etc
il y avait cet élément là et aussi les
gens puis général poids qui est
intéressant c'est que pour les russes
il s'agit d'un moment absolument capital
de dire dans leur présentation en fait
de cet événement
il parlait d'un moment où va se décider
l'avenir du monde est donc cette idée
s'ils voudraient répercuter dans leurs
visions en fait de ce sommet du fait que
au fond la russie revient un peu comme
lui à la cesse cette sorte de d'autres
grands avec lequel décide de l'avenir
toujours 10 eskimos vol puisqu'il ya au
fond de cette obsession de du kremlin de
d'être traitées en égales et au fond le
principal but de cette rencontre de
vladimir poutine avec le byden c'est
d'être reconnu comme un égal et donc le
simple fait de la rencontre est pour lui
déjà une forme la victoire et c'est
évidemment très très différents joe
biden qui doit passer son opinion
publique face aux républicains et aux
partis démocrates y regarder de manière
extrêmement attentive la manière dont il
va se comporter aujourd'hui lui ils
doivent trouver en fait qu'il est
capable de d'être ferme
2 2 mètres une pris une forme de
pression sur poutine sur les sujets
disons qui fâchent comme la question
effectivement de la déstabilisation des
élections américaines
la question de craine la question de la
biélorussie la question des droits de
l'homme en russie de la répression
extrêmement brutale en fête qui se
déroule aujourd'hui à laver et qui a été
accélérée
à la veille du sommet par le pouvoir
russe dans remonterait en fait au fond
que quelle que soit la position
américaine à la position russe
elle c'est tout à fait autre chose ils
font ce qu'ils veulent chez eux vous
voyez il ya tous ces éléments qui jouent
dans cette dans ce début de rencontre
entre les deux il ya vraiment il ya
quand même je dirais une réunion mais en
réalité des positions et des réunions
réunion au sommet aujourd'hui les des
divisions qui sont comme des fossés
béants à l'eau à l'extérieur de la
bâtisse il ya quelques minutes nous nous
voyons maintenant l'intérieur de la
villa lagrange sont assis vladimir
poutine aux côtés de joe biden le
président américain et le président
russe kotaku a enregistré deux affaires
étrangères et leurs ministres des
anthony blinken
donc je pense qu'il laisse encore
quelques caméras les filment et vous
faire quelques photos dans ces minutes
qui arrive l'heure mandeville je voulais
savoir est-ce que des deux chefs d'état
il en est un qui est en position de
force aujourd'hui où il serait peut-être
plus intéressant de demander qui est en
position de faiblesse aujourd'hui je
crois que clairement la position de ce
soir c'est vrai du mieux possible
qu'il occupe aujourd'hui d'abord parce
que tout vient rappeler que c'est la
partie américaine qui a demandé à tenir
ce sommet et que il a fait un moment où
la russie faisait une démonstration
force aussi bien aux frontières de
l'ukraine avec un déploiement
extrêmement spectaculaire de troupes qui
ont laissé craindre d'ailleurs une forme
d' emballement militaire et au moment où
la russie vient de procéder comme je
vous disais à l'instant à usage interne
extrêmement violent on est en plein dans
les suites de la sphère navalni qui a
été emprisonné comme vous savez il ya
quelques mois après avoir été
empoisonnés avec un poison aujourd'hui
toute son équipe est aujourd'hui de
toute son organisation a été dissoute
elle a aujourd'hui le ter qui
d'organisations extrémistes
tous les opposants d'autres
organisations comme celles de russie
ouverte de haute corse qui sont
également aujourd'hui on considère ont
été dissoutes
il ya beaucoup sans partis ont quitté le
pays d'autres sont en danger certains
ont été mis en prison il ya quand même
une situation qui est qu'il est très dur
et aux faux la force de vladimir poutine
c'est qu'il assume cette situation
complètement tu
il n'estime n'avoir pas de compte à
rendre à weiden il a dit de manière très
claire et de solutions l'interrogent sur
ces questions là x comme l'a dit
philippe tout à l'heure il posera des
questions sur ce qui fait apparaître
équivalente à mon avis totalement dire
c'était artificielle et coteaux d'avoir
parce que actuellement les
manifestations qui a eu en russie n'ont
pas été des manifestations violentes et
c'est ce qu'il ne dit absolument pas
c'est à dire quand le concept de ce qui
s'est passé au capitole s'est produit il
ya eu quand même une tentative d'entrer
dans le hub une entrée par la force à
l'intérieur du congrès et j'imagine ce
qui se serait passé en six 6 des
opposants avaient essayé de rentrer dans
la douma d'état par la force
donc on a on a d'un côté des
manifestations pacifiques je vois qu'il
ya eu aucun élément violentes
manifestations de l'opposition qui se
sont soldées par des pressions
extrêmement brutale et de l'autre si
vous voulez la faire du capitole qui
quand même ne peut pas être penser de la
même manière s'il y avait aussi des gens
pacifiques au capitole donc je pense que
ce qui est très intéressant et le gros
problème cabaye tente pour ça qu'il est
en situation de faiblesse c'est qu'il
est face à un président qui nous enfin
l'existence des réalités et des faits
que les dirigeants occidentaux et
américains l'un après l'autre on
essayait de lui présenter lors de leurs
différents médias et ce qui est
intéressant pour vous montrer à quel
point ben hayden était arrivé dans une
situation beaucoup plus difficile c'est
que il s'est extrêmement préparer à
cette rencontre et il ya eu plusieurs
articles qui sont sortis sur ce sujet
notamment sur le site action qui raconte
en fait comment hayden a été briefé
longuement parlé spécial de la russie
pour savoir comment justement essayer eu
d'approché
poutine et ce problème du fait que à
toute question qu'on me pose
il renvoie par une question sur
l'occident manière assez cynique en
faisant comme si la situation était
totalement parallèle donc il ya l on
appelle ça et c'est en fait que à chaque
fois pour lui poser des questions avec
leurs griefs
poutine répond mais alors et chez vous
volent bas au dessus et qu'est ce qui se
passe chez vous donc n'ayant absolument
l'existence de problèmes et c'est vrai
qu'il ya au fond la vraie question qui
se pose aujourd'hui est ce qu'il peut y
avoir
tableau dialogue alors que finalement
chaque partie se retrouve dans un
système de pensée et une rhétorique une
qui semble ne pas pouvoir se rencontrer
cela on assiste depuis plusieurs années
et c'est ça qu'il met des occidentaux je
pense dans une position de faiblesse
alors que poutine à a il faut le dire
avec une masse pria ministre il ya ce
qu'il faut reconnaître a complètement
maîtrisé l'art de tourner les faits et
de de gérer cccc conférence de presse
complexe à son avantage et donc je pense
qu'on avait véritablement d'un côté
quelqu'un qu'il est dément demandeurs
d'une forme de jeu
trèves et côté russe on demande aussi
une forme de trêve mais à ses conditions
c'est à dire que oui on veut bien qu'on
parle beaucoup dans celle des experts
russes d'un retour au format de la
guerre froide ce qui est assez
significatif c'est à dire on est pour un
retour à un cadre des relations comme à
l'époque de l'urss et des états unis
c'est ce que disaient les experts
officiels russes ces derniers jours et
encore ce matin
ce qu'on voyait dans les journaux et
donc ça vous donne une idée du climat
dans lequel soutiennent négociations
merci beaucoup leur mandeville on va
vous laisser repartir parce que vous
avez un papier à écrire pour le figaro
justement et vous allez suivre en
particulier la conférence de presse qui
va suivre
ces sessions de travail entre les deux
dirigeants merci encore pour vos
interventions en direct et vos
éclairages sur ce sommet et les enjeux
de ce sommet entre le président
américain et le président russe
philippe gelie je me tourne vers vous
souhaitez rebondir peut-être sur ce que
j'aime dire leur longue et je pense que
le tout à fait raison sur le plan de
l'affrontement des deux hommes eux mêmes
poutine est en position de force mais je
mets deux bémols à sa date peuvent
d'abord au niveau des pays
on n'est pas dans le même rapport enfin
je pense que ça s'avère c'est que le les
états unis restent évidemment beaucoup
plus puissant que la russie est l'un des
objectifs de byden me semble-t-il pour
cette journée de discussions c'est
justement d'arriver à faire entendre à
poutine que cette position de force
basque kéké dû en partie au fait qu'il
assume les tensions comme l'a très bien
dit lors il assume les tensions
actuelles
ça ne dérange pas tellement mais l'un
des objectifs de byden doit être de lui
faire entendre que ça pourrait devenir
de plus en plus compliqué pour lui de
les assumer et de moins en moins
confortable cib hayden fait entendre à
poutine que cette situation s'étant sion
c'est ces petits coups de canif parce
que ce sont pas ceux sont pas des choses
qui vont déstabiliser
eux qui vont renverser le pouvoir
américain on est plutôt dans une
tactique de guerre asymétrique de 2
c'est pas de la vraie guerre ses dépens
j'appelle ça des coups de canif oui ces
coups de canif ne font pas mal pour
l'instant à youtube hayden mais ne font
pas du tout mal à poutine
tout l'objet de la démarche de bâle doit
être de faire comprendre à poutine que
ça va lui coûter de plus en plus cher
que le prix est remonté je le disais au
début de cet entretien philippe gelie
que cette rencontre entre les deux
hommes qu'on a vécu il ya quelques
minutes maintenant vient clore la
journée la tournée européenne du
président américain joe biden
elle est en est le point d'orgue même
depuis le 9 juin il était en tournée en
europe pour le g7
et puis avec les pays de l'otan et par
ailleurs on peut considérer aussi que
joe biden dans sa démarche d'aller
jusqu'à genève pour rencontrer poutine
même si la rencontre ne se fait pas à
moscou il ya tout de même l'idée d'un
d'un bail dunn qui va jusqu'à poutine
est ce que c'est pas un bon point où un
avantage pour le président russe oui
bien sûr mais je pense que c'est un
leurre c'est à dire que aux yeux du
monde
poutine est installé comme le rival le
plus important le plus préoccupant est
celui qui mérite la première attention
de la part du chef de la première
puissance mondiale
ça c'est ce que dit ce sommet
aujourd'hui sur le papier je pense qu'en
réalité sur un plan de au plan de la
stratégie américaine c'est tout à fait
l'inversé c'est à dire que je pense que
byden veut essayer de cadrer sa relation
avec poutine pour pouvoir passer à autre
chose qui à ses yeux est beaucoup plus
important aujourd'hui donc il donne
il fait ce cadeau abouti de l'installer
aux yeux du monde comme son
interlocuteur problématique numéro un
ça peut pas être son meilleur ami mais
ça peut être son meilleur ennemi ou son
interlocuteur problématique numéro un ce
qui en soi est un statut mondial très
prisé et maintenant les portes vont se
refermer les caméras sont ressortis les
deux hommes ont commencé à discuter sur
le fond et sur le fond encore une fois
il ne s'agit pas d' arriver ce soir avec
une espèce de deux paquets cadeau
magnifique avec un accord bilatéral
magnifique non il s'agit de bien faire
comprendre à l'autre que voilà mes
lignes rouges
voilà ce que je vais faire si vous
continuez à marcher dessus
c'est ça ça marche dans les deux sens ce
qui est encore une fois une chose assez
nouvelle à ses nouvelles
parce que la russie pouvait présenter
une menace pour la sécurité européenne
mais elle n'était pas vraiment jusqu'à
s'immiscer dans le mode de
fonctionnement de la démocratie
américaine sur le plan intérieur et donc
ça c'est relativement nouveau et je
pense que ça donne un nouveau levier à
poutine qui en est parfaitement
conscient et il n'y renoncera pas sans
obtenir quelque chose d'important à ses
yeux on échange on va conclure cette
émission sur un dernier point vous avez
abordé philippe gelie au début de ce
direct à propos de ce sommet entre les
deux hommes de ce meilleur adversaire de
bail donne que représente peut-être
poutine aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'internautes font référence à la chine
aujourd'hui qui était une puissance
qu'on ne peut plus maintenant ignorait
évidemment et qui est rentré dans le
game on va dire
et aujourd'hui c'est la chine l'ennemi
principal entre guillemets de ces deux
pays de ces grandes puissances la chine
est dans l'ombre de ce sommet à tous
niveaux
d'abord comme je les dis parce que je
pense que ça n'est pas le
le blog de petits n'est pas la cible
principale de dubaï donne parce que nous
sommes dans cette espèce de situation
certains m'ont appelé le piège de
thucydide entre sparte et athènes
c'est à dire de la montée en puissance
d'une puissance émergente et le déclin
relatif de la puissance installée
un livre d'un professeur de harvard aux
états unis et qui s'appelle à l'essonne
a démontré que presque dans tous les cas
dans l'histoire où cette configuration
s'est présentée ça s'est soldé par une
guerre entre la puissance en place et la
puissance émergente qui voulait lui
ravir sa première place le seul cas
pratiquement où la guerre a pu être
évité c'est entre deux systèmes de
valeurs complètement similaires c'est à
dire entre l'empiré britannique et la
montée en puissance américaine au début
du 20e siècle
là ya pas eu de guerre entre les deux
mais sinon il ya eu beaucoup de guerre
dont il ya vrai havre et risque de
guerre qui serait certainement une
guerre mondiale entre la chine et les
etats unis c'est ça aujourd'hui l'enjeu
principal dans cette partie là qui est
la vraie partie stratégique
la russie a un rôle mineur mais quand
même important parce que pour l'instant
ce qu'on voit c'est une relative
coordination de la mlv si vous voulez
des malts de la malveillance
encore une fois c'est des petits coups
de canif c'est pas des grandes attaques
mais il y a clairement une relative
coordination entre la chine et la russie
pour embêter et agacer les états unis or
la russie n'a pas objectivement à moyen
terme intérêt à se vendre totalement la
chine 1 la russie un jeu à jouer aussi
comme l'europe peut-être entre les états
unis et la chine
et je pense que c'est un discours que
ben hayden tiendra à poutine en lui
disant mais ok pour l'instant vous
faites votre petit jeu avec les chinois
vous nous marcher sur un sur les pieds
vous nous arracher un nombre ici ou là
ok mais à terme
est ce que c'est vraiment l'intérêt de
la russie que de se mettre
le sillage de la chine sachant qu'il ya
une grande méfiance historique
évidemment entre les deux empires russe
et chinois est donc c'est un des
objectifs annexes je dirais de bail
donne aujourd'hui de faire voir et de
faire comprendre à poutine que il a
intérêt à jouer une partition un peu
plus équilibrée entre la chine et les
états unis
ce sera le mot de la fin et c'est fort
passionnant merci encore philippe gelie
d'avoir participé à ce direct et d'avoir
commenté cette rencontre au sommet entre
le président américain joe biden et son
homologue russe vladimir poutine ils se
sont donc rencontrés ils sont en train
maintenant de travailler ensemble il ya
quelques minutes
il était sur le perron de cette bâtisse
la ville à la grange lieu symbolique
aujourd'hui au bord du lac léman à
genève en suisse
et tout l'après midi jusqu'en début de
soirée les deux hommes les deux
dirigeants vont essayer de trouver des
terrains d'entente ou en tout cas de
s'entretenir sur des sujets importants
et qui crée en ce moment deux grosses
friction entre les deux états
merci encore de nous avoir suivis en
direct sur figaro live et sur youtube
merci encore d'avoir commenté
de votre côté ou d'avoir participé via
vos questions et commentaires sur les
tchats respectifs du figaro et de
youtube
je vous dis à très vite sur figaro live